Hi, my name is Saoirse Ronan...
...and today, I'm going to teach you America how to make the perfect cup of tea.
You fill up your kettle to the desired amount.
So, this is filled up to five cups...
...so we can all have a cup of tea.
You don't use  your kettle to actually serve the tea.
That's wrong.
You have a teapot.
Put your tea bag in there.
You'd have to, usually.
So, we're gonna leave that in there.
Anyway, your kettle's boiled.
You fill up your teapot.
Have your tea bag in there.
Let it brew for about three minutes.
Make sure it's nice and strong.
Pour your tea.
Put your milk in.
It looks awful from here but the idea is there.
Have your cup of tea.
Have a shortbread biscuit.
There you go, life is instantly better for you.